from IBM research and we'll be talking
about improving accuracy private
security off via multiple programming
thank you and thank you for having me so
a few words about myself right so before
joining IBM and working on transporting
machine learning I was actually trained
as a signal processor uh and of course
my information Theory skills has been
very rusted now and then probably you
can sense I'm working on AI and deep
learning now because I'm using
PowerPoints to do my presentations okay
but nonetheless I'm going to try to show
you something I'm very passionately
excited about right it's called the
model reprogramming and I'm going to
walk you through an example of how to
use this model reprogramming to improve
uh task performance especially accuracy
given differential privacy constraints
and then I'm going to show you what are
the existing available Theory to explain
the success of model reprogramming and
finally I'm going to post a challenge
and also humble requests like to
everyone in the room right to ask for
developing information theoretical tools
to tackle and understand the theoretical
limits and foundations for this problem
I believe there's a lot of things we can
do together
okay so let's start with what is model
reprogram and I want to have a small
detour to this uh Foundation model right
so no matter you like this turn or not
but this is something you know coined by
a bunch of us tempered researchers last
year right basically signifying a new
era and a new machine learning Paradigm
that we have witnessing right it's a
pre-training and fine-tuning Paradigm so
there is a foundation model that is
pre-trained on a very large scale data
like Wikipedia skill to learn the
general representations of different
modalities and once you have that
Foundation model and also their generic
representations you can efficiently fine
tune them on different Downstream tasks
with the label data right so when I was
giving a tutorial at the new ribs in
December right about the same time I
charge gbt just the release and we
literally need to spend like 10 pages of
slides to explain to people why it's
Foundation model right it uses the
self-supervised learning to do
pre-training and how to say to
fine-tuning but now right I have a very
like information Optimum way to share
how why is Foundation model right so the
first question will be okay have you
heard of charge GPT and then they will
say yes and then I will say okay so gpd3
is the foundation model and then charge
gbd is the fine-tuned foundation model
on a chatbot application right so no
information optimal way of explaining
what Foundation model it is and why uh
now so so much more of the AI focus is
on these Foundation models
so from our perspective with those
Foundation models right we are basically
giving a pool of available pre-trained
models right so we are asking the
question of how can we build upon these
preacher models to do something else
right to solve uh different tasks
especially the tasks in resource limited
domains right so essentially what we are
proposing is a new framework of model
reprogramming that basically take a
pre-trend uh model and then we froze it
which means we are not changing the
weights during the fine tuning stage and
instead we are inserting two you know
chainable layers right or
Transformations if you like at input and
output of the pre-trained model uh to
repurpose the model to do something new
and do something else and we have
several examples like reprogramming
speech models to do time series
classification reprogramming English
language models to do molecule learning
and also reprogramming computer region
models to do biomedical measurements uh
classification tasks and this is really
exciting because uh this model
reprogramming actually offers a very
good parameter efficiency and
reusability right so comparing to
different machine learning paradigms by
Foundation models it needs to trend on a
very large amount of data and also have
billions of Channel parameters uh and
similar simpler tasks specifically
learning right but with model
reprogramming because we only need to
train the parameters that of the layers
we inserted by is also is a very
parameter efficient and you can kind of
understand why it also benefits
differential privacy as well and I was
very excited about this topic and wrote
a survey paper on on this direction as
well
school last week
okay so I would like to uh quote uh Sir
Isaac Newton right if I've seen further
It Is by standing on the shoulders of
giants right and I think this pretty
much will describe to what it is our
expectation about Foundation model and
the relationship to reprogramming right
so it is true that in some data Rich
domains right like the image text audio
code right there are abundant data and
we can train Foundation models but that
is not the end of the story there are
regimes and scenarios where we only have
limited data right like biomedical image
tasks they are cases where in some
domains they are simply no good pre-term
model exist right or they are scenarios
where a researcher cannot afford the
cost of training a foundation model from
scratch limited resource or there are
some training constraints right like for
example those imposed by differential
privacy in those scenarios right we I
believe we need a new alternative right
a resource efficient way of fine-tuning
this application model to unleash the
power of a foundation model to do this
new tasks
okay so let me show you one example of
how cost means Foundation models can be
right so this is an example of a
charging BT right so this is the
basically every Foundation model is
trend on large-scale data and then who
is a high capacity Obedience of
parameters neural Nets and then with
that we can find you on different
Downstream tasks right uh so charge gbp3
as an example right it is trend on one
thousand billion tokens and with the one
175 billion training parameters and
estimated the training cost is 12
million right to Trend such One
Foundation model
now right we are in entering the gbp4
error right so according to uh some
um some recording uh from the open ISP
or right same ultimate right so people
are estimating the cost of training gbd4
is about 100 million right but at the
recent event right uh same actually said
is more than 100 million right so it's
pretty much a very very expensive to
train such a foundation model
okay so uh the as already I described
the settings I already described is that
in the standard setting right if we have
abundant resource right we can afford
this pre-training and fighting strategy
but here we are focusing on this
resource limited setting right we want
to use these Foundation models to solve
a new task a new machine learning task
in a new domain especially in a resource
limited domain uh in this case we are
doing reprogramming instead of doing you
know standard fine-tuning to fine-tune
the weights of the foundation mode
and you may now ask me the question okay
so how is this different from transfer
learning right so it depends on what uh
what what do you mean by transfer
learning right but my view of Transport
learning is the standard view like you
take a pre-trained model with the
pre-trained weights and then you are
going to fine-tune some of the
parameters in the preacher model to do
that to do a downstream task
uh on contrast right model reprogramming
we are doing uh things in a different
way in the sense that we are not
changing the pressure amount of weights
all the way to the end and we are really
taking a model trend on domain a to
solve a different problem in domain B
and these two domains right can be like
a very unrelated right like this time
series and speech example I I showed you
earlier
yeah okay so finally before I go to the
technical details I also want to show
some uh backgrounds right so this
reprogramming idea I was originally cast
as the adversary programming because at
the time right they discovered that it
is possible to reprogram a pre-trained
model to do some something else right
something new that is now originally
designed by the by the model developer
so there were some concerns about how
attackers can repurpose a pre-trained
model to do something else without the
consent of the model developer uh and in
the first paper I published in 2017
there are they show some works of a
reprogramming imagenet model right to do
some mist or c510 classification
problems but if you look closely the
accuracy I kind of get only mediocre
accuracy so there's nothing interesting
to explore other than you know you can
you can successfully reprogram a model
to do something else
okay so now with this more powerful
pre-trained models and Foundation models
or betray models or not right how can we
leverage these powers and to do more
interesting tasks it was also especially
with the reprogramming so I'm going to
show you an example using a framework
that we propose called the black box
adversary program so it's a way of
reprogramming a black box model to do
something new
um so the setting is like this where we
are given a pre-trained a model right in
this case even a black box model Black
Box meaning you can only get to observe
the output of the model right like a
classification API and you will never
know what is the architecture or ways in
inside that model and we are trying to
ask how can we reprogram this model
reprogram API right to do something new
right for example uh reprogrammer
imagenet a pre-trained model to do a
biomedical classification tasks
so let me use this figure to explain how
this work is done right in the in the
illustrative example right so we are
given a pre-trained model like here
imagenet model and given any input it
will output a prediction on all the
imaginary classes
now we are given a downstream task right
and in some data sets from a Target
domain and then the tasks can be very
different right so for example those are
biomedical image classification tasks uh
now how can we leverage uh this
pre-trained model to help us solve the
problem so there are essentially two
three steps right the first step will be
this input transformation step right so
the first thing we will do is we will
put the target data at the center of the
inputs of the pre-trained imagenet and
then we will we will also leave some
boundary uh to be a trainable parameter
right some sort of input transformation
that is trainable right so and then we
get a transformed uh data input for a
Target domain uh the next thing we will
do is we will pass the data to the
pre-trip model and of course the
predictions right of those transformed
data inputs will be on the imagenet uh
class label space so the next thing we
should do is we should map The Source
label to the Target label right so we
should specify okay before this says
these sets of imaginary class labels we
are going to map it to a downstream
label here ASD means the autism spectrum
disorder right it's a binary
classification for one of these data
sets and I'm going to map the other set
of the classes to the the second class
the non-sd class right so end to end
right the I get a model that is working
on a Target domain right it starts from
taking the input in the Target domain
and then predict something uh at the
Target label space as well
so finally the third step is I'm going
to train uh what whatever chainable
parameters I introduce at the input and
output uh to minimize the loss that we
designed for the Target domain and this
chaining right can be done in a black
box where if we are dealing with the
blackbox model right using like zero
solder optimization or any gradient free
techniques that the the Terra the first
stage keynote speaker talked about
and noticeably uh in the entire process
we are not requesting to change the
weights of the pre-trained model all we
do is to insert these new modules at the
beginning and end of the model right to
enable this sort of transfer learning
scenario but I I prefer to call it
reprogramming
okay so mathematically it's actually
pretty simple to formulate as well so we
are given a pre-trend classifier it can
be a black box model a blobbox function
that basically take any input right
rescale between minus and one with
Dimension D and then it will outputs
predictions right like soft Max outputs
over the K classes right uh in the in
the source domain and now we are given a
set of data from a downstream uh domain
right assuming and we are assuming the
the target data has a smaller Dimension
than the source data so we can allow
some extra space right to introduce
these chainable for the patients yes
like a score on zero
it's a real value but after taking
logically can be zero to one so it
doesn't really matter
okay it's just a matter of what you get
as an output of the black box that's yes
okay so so those are the the set of
trainable parameters that we introduced
as a universal for the patient to every
Target inputs
okay so uh mathematically right we are
given this target data right TI and then
we first first thing we will do is we
will Zero Pat the target data to to make
sure the padded image will have the same
size as the imagenet uh data and then we
will introduce these chainable parameter
the perturbation P right which is
nothing but uh this is a mask function
right so we are basically introducing a
mask mask into asking the model to add
perturbation to only to the Border or
you can add the perturbation inside the
image as well uh but basically uh our
empirical resource suggests that you you
the best way you should do is to put the
target data at the center of the the
inputs and also only Trend those uh
border parameters the pixel values that
is usually the best configuration so
this W will be the universal chainable
parameter and of course you can consider
more complicated setting by even
introducing a small neural Nets try to
introduce this input perturbation or
transformation functions
uh so how do we map the outputs right so
the easiest thing that we can do is to
do random mapping right so you can
randomly assign uh some Source labels to
map to a Target label right it's
actually a a mapping that you can design
right so for example here I'm basically
saying the the prediction outputs over
the model output of the ASD class will
be the average of the three uh Source
class images
Source classes attach goldfish and
hammerhead
we can do something even slightly
sophisticated right so before we do this
label mapping like we can just fit in
those those Target data in observe what
is the best respond data class in the
source domain and we can do sort of with
the frequency based mapping and normally
that will improve the accuracy as well
okay and once we have the mapping and
the input transformation the final thing
is trending right so here we can take
any preferred uh Target domain uh task
and then we can train uh those the
parameters that we introduced right here
uh the input the perturbations
parameters by W and then the training
depends on the scenarios if there's a
block box right we will use this
gradient free based method to update uh
the the weights until it converges if
it's a y box right then we can just
simply use the gradient-based approach
right to optimize the parameters
associated with the information
transformation plot so that that is
basically a simple example of how this
modeling program is working for uh this
image classification task
and as I indicated earlier on right this
is a very general framework right so we
have applied this technique and this
principle to different modalities and
different applications and they can be
all summarized into this high level
algorithmic procedures right so we are
given a set of Target domain data
um and then we can initialize the the
input per division input transformation
and output mapping layer with some
parameters Theta and W right and then
you do this input transformation and
output mappings through some learning
mechanisms and training mechanisms and
then you only Trend uh this is C time W
line the two sets of parameters that you
introduced to reprogram a pre-trained
model and finally you will get a
reprogrammed model for your Downstream
task
okay so this is a next two slides I'm
going to quickly show and convince you
that this is actually a very a very nice
alternative to solve problems in the
resource limited setting so this is the
ASD uh classification example I talked
about uh previously right so this is a
binary classification task and each
class only have about the 500 images and
these are actually the the brain
correlation graphs obtained from real
measurements so they are very expensive
to annotate and do uh collect the data
in scale right so while we can observe
is that the uh AR means a white box
reprogramming and BR means lab as we
programming so both cases right actually
achieve the state of VR resource and we
stay assets and they perform much better
to comparing to changing from scratch
and even a simple transport learning and
they also outperform the
state-of-the-art resource that actually
requires very complicated hand designed
uh learning rules and feature learning
process
so we can see that by simply leveraging
uh the the model pre-trained on another
domain right in this case the general
image classification task right we can
already apply these tools to solve these
problems and Achieve new therapy art in
this resource limited domains foreign
models right so one interesting
experiment that we do is we upload a
traffic sign classification data set to
Microsoft API and then this is the kind
of the auto machine learning uh setting
where they will uh give us the model
right to us to to predict the uh to to
predict any images with this traffic
signs but they would not they will let
us know why it's the the model
architecture or the weights uh in this
case right we can also reprogram this
API to do ASD classification right so if
you spend like 20 dollars then you can
get the ASD class CB classified with
about 67.8 percent accuracy which is
actually a very cost effective solution
to you still VR models but for solving
your uh difficult problems at hand
okay uh and finally I would like to make
some remarks about the connections
between model reprogramming and prompt
right so prompting is again another
parameter efficient way right to play
with the state-of-r machine learning
models so my definition will be you know
in computer region domain if your Source
model and your Downstream tasks are both
from the computer region domain then
model reprogramming is basically the
same as video prompt
right so kind of independently uh you
take into like about two years ago right
independently a group of researchers
from MIT invented this word video
prompting right so what they are doing
here is again very similar and they
actually add adversary programming as a
baseline as well right so you add some
video prompt here individual point is
nothing but this input Transformations
that we introduced uh in the model
reprogramming framework and then they
are going to also assign some output
label mapping to solve a downstream task
uh what's more interesting is that they
also show this thing is also doable for
a clip right which is the sale of the
art uh text image join encoder model so
they can reprogram by adding some visual
prompt but you can now ask the models
who say this is a photo of something and
with that right with this simple uh
prompting ideas right you will get a
very high accuracy uh for those clip
models
so in a recent work we also keep
exploring the benefits of the importance
of this label mapping right so in the
recent workout we are going to present
at the cvcr next month uh is we figure
out that the iterative label mapping is
actually a key uh to achieve the high
accuracy for model reprogram right so
this is a kind of the wrong time wrong
time example during training time right
so given this target image right so for
example a marigold image right and we
keep asking the model to find the best
matching label according to the eat from
The Source label space to the Target
label space so you can see as the
training loss becomes a chance to
converge like you kind of find a the
best source label that maps to the
Target label with high semantics right
so you can map this orange class to the
marigold target class because they
because they have a high similarity and
also semantics in in the space of their
representations and also similarly it is
a three-party right because can be
mapped ego right because they share some
higher level or similar semantics
and there are more examples in our
slides on different Downstream tasks but
the most interesting thing is like on
clip right we can also do the same thing
uh by treating uh different prompt
templates as a source label and then you
can ask okay given the target task and
given the target label right what is the
best prompt uh template I should use uh
to improve the accuracy of prompting
right so in this case compared to the
naive visual prompting right with this
iterative label mapping by finding out
the best prompt templates we can
actually improve the accuracy by a
significant amount and also if you look
at the data scalability in terms of how
many data you have to do visual
prompting or reprogramming right uh this
iterative label mapping always give you
a significantly better accuracy compared
to you know using a fixed label map
okay so how is this yes
the input not the visual part of the
input yes yes so so while you are
describing is what they call a prefix
tuning right so prompting was prompting
it was originally proposed in natural
language processing but when it comes to
computer region right people are asking
how do we do promptings right in the
computer region states that's why they
invented this video prompt device so you
can now think about the
uh this attention about garbage being
some sort of prefixed uh token like
inserted by to prompt the model to stop
the cuts even in the vision language
models usually I've seen people insert
the prompts in the text portion yes the
learnable fronts yes yes yeah so they
are also more advanced the method called
the video from tuning right so in this
case if you are using a Transformer here
right then you can look at the token
embeddings and insert some turnable
tokens uh to do video prompt right but
here we are simply looking at the input
level the business
foreign
programming right in the field of a
differential privacy fine tuning right
so the setup is again I have a
pre-trained source model nice trend on
non-private data and now my Downstream
task is some privacy sensitive data and
then I'm going to train uh the model to
maximize the utility on the downstream
task but with some differential privacy
constraints right and and we can compare
different approaches so I like we can
use a model reprogramming to do so right
by introducing again the input and
output churnable layers or we can do
four fine tuning which means you need to
fine-tune every uh pre-trained model
weights we can also do this partial fine
tuning where you only fine-tune the last
few layers of a pre-trip model right so
so those are like a value based nights
and of course we should also compare to
training from scratch right now using a
pre-trained weights at all and the
notion of BP We are following is like a
very standard episode uh I guess you are
tired of it so I will skip the
definition
okay so we can also extend this case to
uh both centralized and Federated
learning setting right so in the
centralized setting right we are
training a model uh with with a privacy
budget in the Federated learning right
we can still use this noisy SGD ideas
with clipping right so we do some noise
SGD and clipping at the client side and
at the server side right yeah basically
basically doing the same standard
Federated averaging protocol by
averaging the noisy gradients they
collected from the clients and exchange
uh those average gradients back to the
clients to do Federated learning also
the the uh the reprogramming idea right
fits pretty well in both schemes right
so for the Federated learning setting we
are basically asking the clients to own
to initialize all right their local
version of the reprogram model using
their local uh input and output layers
and then throughout this application
learning protocol they will learn uh
Global input output transformation there
and that could uh
leverage the Privacy budget better
so here are some like a very simple
examples to show how well right this
idea performs right so unlock x-axis I'm
plotting the apps on the Privacy budget
and on the y-axis I'm comparing the
accuracy of different training pipelines
right model reprogramming the red one
for fine tuning right uh actually the
worst one because there are too many
parameters to trade uh also Trend and
say also same story for train from
scratch and the only competitive method
is this a partial fine tuning where you
only fine tune the last layer of a
pre-trim model but still you notice a
very big gap between model reprogramming
and standard transfer learning uh in in
both cases
[Music]
okay so now Beyond right bphgd right
there we can also adapt this model
reprogram into different DP training
mechanisms right so in other popular
action will be the Pate right method
introduced by paper not and others
so for those of you who are not familiar
with Pate right this is a semi
supervised machine learning setups right
where uh you first uh separate your
private data into several destroying
sets and then you train uh what is so
called teacher model on those disjoint
sets uh and then uh you are also given a
set of unlabeled data and you are going
to use those teacher models to give a
prediction on the label that I said and
use that as a distillation process to
Trend your final uh student model and
this is arguably a better way of
leveraging a privacy budget and usually
get a better accuracy if you use a pate
instead of dpsgd although the setup is
not quite the same so how how does the
model reprogram player role here right
so we simply replace the teacher model
right is used in Pate with this
reprogrammed teacher model right so when
we are training those teacher models we
are again only using this video
prompting or you know input
transformation idea plus some trainable
label typing function instead of
training the teacher model from scratch
so this idea is pretty simple but the
resource is very significant but I
should also ask Peter to audit our
performance for sure
and when we use the models pre-trained
on image that we actually get the state
of VR results using this pate class
visual prompting ID or party plus a
reprogramming ideas
and of course by the quality of the
pre-trained model is a very takes a very
significant role right so we do some
ovulation study by you know taking
different models pre-training image net
right so like a strong like a typical uh
convolutional neuralness resnet all the
way to more recent Transformer based
architecture like a swing Transformers
and what we do see is that uh the more
uh capable right uh models right those
Source models with better accuracy on
their original Source task actually also
delivers a better accuracy privacy
trade-off uh in the downstream task
right so given the same Epsilon budgets
right a more advanced more accurate
Source model will give also a better
accuracy on the target target task
uh we also show something on the cross
domain uh task right so if you think
imagenes and supporting are too similar
we can actually do this reprogramming
from Imaging models to do a blood and
misclassification tasks and in this case
we are even seeing a more significant
gain compared to this standard transfer
learning ppsgd results
yes
reprogramming with other with high-ching
methods yes yes that would be like like
this one so this transfer uh it's
basically taking a feature mode or only
fighting some layers
but fine-tuning layers uh is not the
only way like they're like a lower
type of oh yeah yes yeah don't write
something that we are investigating but
I I haven't had the comparison yes I I
would say also benefits from uh it will
also improve privacy activities
trade-off for sure because of the
parameter Ephesians
okay so you know just out of curiosity
we want to know why model reprogramming
works and the the we have a very
preliminary results of why model
reprogramming works right so this is not
really about knowledge transfer right
that people talk about intrinsical
learning because we have shown model
reprogramming can work well in this
cross domain learning setups right so
some theory that we cooked out is that
the the target risk right the loss on
the target domain is actually bounded by
the submission of two terms right the
source the first thing is the source
risk basically translating to how well
your model is on the source task right
like what we should that we have shown
in the previous slide like a suing
Transformer did better than other uh
neural Nets right because EU has a
better accuracy on the source task the
second loss which is the most
interesting one is called the
representation alignment loss right so
intuitively if we are going to reprogram
a doc versus cat classifier 2 and other
binary classification tasks right so
what is the optimum way of reprogramming
is to learn how to align one class label
to Doc any other class right to catch
right if we have a perfect
representation alignment then we can
just reuse the classification rule of a
cat and dog to solve the new binary
classification task right so if the
replenished alignment between source and
task labels data are perfect then we
basically can make this term zero and
then we can ensure that the target risk
is upper bounded by The Source risk
so this is just some uh numerical
validation right so when we Trend uh the
reprogrammed models that when we get
high accuracy and I would like to focus
on the third row right which is the
slice washer stand distance between the
source data and the reprogrammed Target
data's representation so you do see that
when the accuracy goes high right the
distance right statistical distance
between these two sets of distributions
become closer which means the reponation
alignment loss right is actually lower
so this is implicitly battery
programming is learn how to re reprogram
or align the representations from the
target domain to the source domain
and this is just some Disney plot right
to convince you that the before and
after reprogramming we do see this a
clear separation uh using reprogramming
it actually gives a better separability
in a representation space when you
compare the programming to transfer
learning
let's see
oh it's like a Disney plus yes
projection yes okay so in the interest
time I'm going to skip this slide but
this is just like a formal uh
theoretical statement of why just the
described
okay so finally right I think the most
important page right a humble request
and ask for information theorists right
so you know when I present this
reprogramming ideas right I I was
thinking about this uh Channel Theory
Channel capacity and this is uh uh and
Source coding and channel coding that I
learned you know through my Graduate
Studies right so no interesting question
to ask is that can we formulate right
this reprogramming problem as a way of
understanding Channel capacity right so
now we have a pre-trained and Frozen
right pre-train model right so we can
view it as a channel like a given
Channel now your input will be a
downstream task and data you want to
solve and the output will be a
reprogrammed model so interesting thing
to ask is that so what uh what is the
capacity what is the limitation of this
pre-train model right what tasks can be
reprogrammed and solved successfully and
whatnot right and what is the best way
right to compress The Source data so
that uh the preacher model I can learn
better and in terms of of a given one
channel right so what is the best way
right given some constraints like a
differential privacy or any like a noise
constraints what is the maximum uh
achievable performance right that can be
done using reprogramming so you know my
guts tell me like the information
theories uh tools I should be very
useful to answer questions like this
right given that now we are not changing
the weights of the feature model at all
right so we can now pretty much think of
it as a given Channel and the challenge
is like to understand what this channel
provides right and what tasks can be
learned through this Channel and what
cannot be learned through this channel
so some simple takeaways right I
basically present you a new uh
fine-tuning alternative called the model
reprogramming and it has a shown a lot
of empirical success in many different
domains especially in this privacy
constraint uh fine-tuning scenarios and
it is truly 100 compatible to existing
DP training methods
um and I basically would like to have
more discussion as what can be done in
terms of the theory understand the
limitations and build New Foundations
for this new
um parameter efficient tuning pipelines
including like Laura like early I just
mentioned
um and finally this is the slide for
codes and references but I will stop
here and open the floor for questions
you have time for a couple of questions
I have a question
so
can I look
on the programming forget the front end
of course you're having fun the back end
is just trading a last layer or I mean
you already have just one output or
maybe soft Max okay so you're just
massaging that also the inputs you also
need to do something at the input
because when you when you massage the
input it will change the representation
in all the subsequent layers and that
actually adds a lot of power to align
the representation comparing to only add
something at the end of the month
yes
because I'm surprised you have apple
bound
and you claim that you can actually get
the target Festival in less than the
sources I find that little surprise yeah
the only if the second time goes to zero
right so the interesting thing is how
can you design input
expresso control learn we still have
such that the The Source will be
Plantation I will be totally aligned to
the Target implementation so if you have
a perfect alignment then these are
watches time one distance will be zero
and then you can guarantee the target
loss is upper bounded by the source code
but that is the ideal setting right so
in practice like when we may actually
measure these watches that one distance
right it's actually never zero just it
will become smaller once you enable this
reprogramming framework
I missed
are you using uh just a grouping of
labels or are you doing uh a weighted
average of the score they're on top I
just I just didn't understand what yeah
so that is more on implementation style
so we introduced like a label mapping
right but also for a Visa Federated
learning scenario we are actually using
a linear attendable layer instead of
label management right so it really
depends it's actually it matters of our
Implement what we call an automatic
label so it can be like a non-parametric
like assigning Source labels to Target
labels or you can just simply add a
linear transformation layer to learn the
math
you know take the the speaker again
[Applause]
the doors in this building will lock at
5 PM so the poster session ends at 5 30
but if you leave after five you probably
won't be able to get back in a little
bit
Yeah the food is going to be served
upstairs